hey Ron I'm a be sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen so today we are gonna be doing
another what I in a date you can review
and as you can see we are in the new
studio so we're very excited to be here
as you can see through qualy still a lot
of things that we need to do
cosmetically we also need to like add a
roof or like a ceiling situation because
you can hear the rain quite loud it's
raining really really heavily today but
we're really excited nonetheless and I
want to give a big THANK YOU to
KitchenAid for sponsoring the appliances
here they are amazing and I'm so excited
to kind of get some really great use out
of them so you can check out the links
below in the description to find out
what I've got in the kitchen and today
we're gonna be reviewing mega and Matt
from Quito connect they are keto
bloggers youtubers they also have a
podcast called keto for normies
and they recently updated what I ended a
video for what they eat post birth
because thangka is a new mom she's
breastfeeding and we're gonna talk a
little bit about pregnancy and
breastfeeding with Keo so before we get
into the video I want to of course give
a little bit of a background err on the
keto diet this has been around for
decades of course however its recently
gained a lot of popularity because of
its supposed weight-loss benefits and of
course you know we're gonna talk about
that but basically the keto diet means
that you're consuming a high amount of
fat in the diet a moderate amount of
protein and very little carbs so most
diets have you between 20 to 50 grams of
carbs max or about 5 percent of your
total calories for the day research to
date suggests that keto is safe for most
people and I do believe that in some
clinical settings it may have some
benefits so for example the keto diet
has been used for decades to treat
epileptic seizures there's also some
evolving research to suggest that it may
help with managing blood sugars and
insulin levels in people with type 2
diabetes and finally there is some
really early preliminary research
looking at its impact on things like
Parkinson's disease and Alzheimer's
however with the exception of epilepsy
the research is really still in its
infancy and I think we need a lot more
larger more better controlled studies to
see how keto diet affects a lot
these different diseases but of course I
know most of you are wondering about the
weight loss benefits so let's get into
that now research has found that the
keto diet may be effective at promoting
short term weight loss however long-term
weight loss as you know with pretty much
every other diet is where things start
to get a little bit murky in a 2013
meta-analysis researchers found that
those following the keto diet lost an
average of 0.91 kilograms more than
people who were following a low-fat diet
after two years and while the
statistical analysis would suggest that
this is a significant difference in
weight loss in the real world after two
years is two pounds really gonna make a
difference
probably not in another two year study
researchers found that people who are
following the keto diet did lose
significantly more weight than those
following the low-fat diet however most
of this weight loss happen in the first
few months of the diet which is often as
a result of water weight loss and not
surprisingly there was some weight
regain the longer the person stayed on
the diet this study also had a really
high dropout rate suggesting that the
keto diet is often one that a lot of
people cannot maintain in the long term
listen if you want to do the keto diet
for whatever reason you do you if it
really improves your well-being your
health and your life in general amazing
however I do have some issues when it
comes to doing the keto diet while
pregnant or breastfeeding which is what
makeup practices herself but before we
get into the what I in today that was
shot post pregnancy while breastfeeding
I want to talk about why it is
contraindicated to be doing keto while
with child first of all is potential
nutritional deficiencies so one major
red flag when it comes to any diet
during pregnancy is a concern over
getting adequate nutrition to both
mother and fetus particularly with
nutrients like folate now fully is a B
vitamin that is found predominantly in
things like whole grains and that's
really imperative to preventing neural
tube defect theoretically this really
should not be an issue on keto because
fully it is also present in a lot of
keto upper foods like leafy
beans asparagus broccoli and eggs
however in a study with over 11,000
women they found that those who are
following a low-carb diet had less than
half of the average folic acid intake as
those who consumed carbs furthermore
they found that those who are on a
low-carb diet had 30% higher chance of
having an infant with neural tube
defects and this study defined low-carb
diet as 95 grams of carbs per day or
less I mean most keto diets have people
on 20 to 50 grams of carbs per day so
you can see where my concern lies they
also found that those who had planned
pregnancies who also followed a low-carb
diet did not see that increased risk of
neural tube defects in other words this
could be a moot point as long as you're
taking your prenatal supplement with at
least 400 micrograms of folic acid
ideally before conception even begins
which I've talked about prior in other
videos as well as getting in those
vegetables that we just talked about
number 2 constipation now constipation
is a side effect that's very common in
both the keto diet and in pregnancy in
general mainly because a lot of
high-fiber foods tend to be higher in
carbs so think things like whole grains
and legumes and some fruits and some
vegetables while fiber is not considered
a carb on keto a lot of people who are
following a low-carb diet or keto diet
do tend to feel constipated and not be
getting enough fiber simply because
they're avoiding a lot of those
high-fiber foods if you're following a
keto diet make sure that the carbs that
you do choose are higher in fiber and
also that you're getting in lots of
those fiber rich veggies not to mention
you definitely also want to be getting
in lots of water and exercise number
three is fetal development concerns we
do know that in general infants brains
depend on glucose for energy so we don't
know if forcing them to convert to
ketone energy will have any adverse
effect however in one mouse study they
found that when mice were put on the
keto diet and then got pregnant they had
a higher likelihood of having embryos
with abnormal size organs so we saw
enlarged hearts or smaller brains all of
which of course have health implications
while this is clearly a concern and
obviously sounds really really
scary I would say that we really just
don't have any evidence to suggest that
this would happen necessarily in humans
and because we don't have that research
we really cannot say for certain whether
or not the keto diet is safe in
pregnancy
finally pregnancy is just not the time
to be going on a weight-loss diet now
I'm not suggesting necessarily that this
is Makos goal here I know she was kind
of on a keto diet before she was even
pregnant however I just want to flag
this as a general kind of piece of
information to take into consideration
when you're thinking about going keto
while you're pregnant
so generally as we know pregnancy is a
time where we actually encourage to gain
weight remember you are trying to grow
another human at the same time as you're
trying to nourish your own body if
you're losing weight while pregnant
you're definitely running the risk of
not providing enough nutrition to both
you and babe of course always speak your
healthcare provider first however it's
my professional and personal opinion
that if you are thinking about doing
keto to lose weight and you're pregnant
now is just not the time now is
ultimately not the time to be making any
kind of drastic changes to your diet or
exercise regime okay so let's take a
look at where mega is today with her
breastfeeding and keto journey and a
scoop of collagen and this cool Yeti
mother got from out yeah he's so
overpriced so right off the bat [ __ ] is
having some decaf coffee which is great
however I want to just flag that you
don't need to necessarily be avoiding
caffeine if you're nursing or pregnant
thank God the recommendation is to just
limit yourself during pregnancy and
breastfeeding to about 300 milligrams of
caffeine per day which works out to be
about 2 to 3 cups of coffee depending on
the brand so when it comes to
supplements I find some of these are
kind of overkill so MCT powder is a
medium chain triglyceride powder that's
absorbed differently and more easily
than longer chain fatty acids that are
found in a lot of different foods that
combined with the coconut oil which is
pretty much being praised
cuz of its medium chain triglycerides
seems kind of redundant to me I kind of
just think like one source of fat per
cup of coffee would probably be okay so
the collagen powder is derived from the
most abundant source of protein in the
body so it doesn't really provide any
fat however it does provide a little bit
of protein in there and there's a lot of
debate over the merits of collagen
powder
however some research does suggest that
it may have some benefits when it comes
to joint health and skin health okay so
let's take a look at what mega is having
for breakfast it's like eight calories
zero carbs it's basically just good for
filling doesn't really taste like much
either
I love making breakfast tacos so this is
perfect for that I think for twelve of
them it was like five or six bucks I
think most days so then for me and this
is key right here green salsa I'm all
about a green salsa it's a little spicy
red sauce is for suckas
this isn't really salsa though I guess
this is Tabasco pepper sauce it's more
mild than normal Tabasco I like it local
so first of all six bucks for like
twelve little egg wraps that apparently
don't taste like anything seems
excessive but let's talk about the meal
itself so there's quite a lot of protein
going on here most people can only
digest about twenty or thirty grams of
protein per sitting or per meal and this
has about twice that so I do question
how well it's being digested I would
also love to see a little bit less
sodium there's a lot of process heat
going in there and also would love to
see some vegetables I mean would it kill
someone to just throw a little vegetable
in there some salsa some guacamole some
bell peppers I mean I would take an
onion at this point remember we talked
about constipation this is how that
happens
just throw a batch in there all right
let's move on to
lunch is your kebabs
Wow beautiful you have the chicken that
bears the squash the mushrooms which are
gross oh look at that big garlic that
looks awesome
I love this meal because we've got some
protein we've got a variety of colorful
vegetables that roasted garlic looks
amazing
so I proof all right let's look at
dinner and then brussel sprouts
and this is a recipe for our food
bloggers I'll link it below
it's Brussels sprouts but I didn't do
bacon I did ghee and garlic shallot then
we got a sponsor for the video today
that's a lot of meat that's that is a
that is a good healthy portion of meat
and like I said earlier when it came to
the breakfast I just feel like this is a
lot of protein to be digesting in one
meal so like I said most people are only
digesting like 20 to 30 grams of protein
per sitting this is easily three times
that along with quite a lot of fat as
well which I get is the keto diet and
that's the purpose but it seems like it
would be really heavy in the get okay so
we've seen their meals let's take a look
at what baby's eating so I think that's
gonna be the cheap it's simple I want
instant gratification that the baby
likes me eat this and be happy okay so
like we talked about with keto and
pregnancy there really isn't a whole lot
of research when it comes to lactation
and the keto diet however the medical
community does have some concerns
number one is ketoacidosis exacerbated
by lactation a number of published case
studies have found healthy young women
who are following the keto diet being
admitted to the hospital with severe
ketoacidosis in other words their ketone
levels got so high that their blood pH
became out of the normal range which of
course is very life-threatening
well most non lactating women can safely
be in ketosis there's a higher risk of
ketoacidosis in
hating women because they require more
energy from fat to produce breast milk
so they're already burning fat and by
default more ketones are produced which
creates an acidic environment and as a
result ketoacidosis so next let's talk
about the impact of the keto diet on
breast milk composition and the
nutrition for the baby so in one study
they looked at mice who were put on a
ketogenic diet while lactating to see if
the breast milk nutrition affected the
nutrition of the baby the lactating mice
were on the keto diet experienced severe
physiological stress and ketoacidosis
and in fact all of the keto diet
lactating mice died and their offspring
were considered small for size well I
think this is important information
breastfeeding mamas do not freak out
this is not meant to scare you or mom
shame you I mean we all have a
mother-in-law for that this adjustment
to share some really really really
preliminary information and basically
this is all we have this is still just
based on mice research so we definitely
cannot extrapolate this to humans yet
the research we have to date suggests
that we should really be cautious when
considering any diet while breastfeeding
including the keto diet however without
any strong evidence either way I think
the best thing that we can do if you are
considering your keto diet while
breastfeeding is to work closely with
your doctor and a registered dietician
to make sure you're doing it in the
safest way possible
this may include measuring your ketones
more regularly or monitoring any
abnormal symptoms like nausea and
vomiting a little bit more closely but
it's really not recommended to be
following the keto diet while
breastfeeding or pregnant without any
medical supervision okay let's get back
to the food baby pee dinner so there
they're good to go bars 160 calories 13
fat six protein 15 total carbs of which
seven are fiber and five are with route
all three in that carbs total I don't
really like it that much a tried one so
the flavor isn't too intense that's
vanilla almond but the texture is
nothing like any other bar and so I'm
always like craving different textures
and so it's nice to have the options
it's very like a dense muffin right okay
so a lot of these
car bars contain some kind of sugar
alcohol or artificial sweetener to add
sweetness so in this case she is talking
about this one having erythritol which
is a sugar alcohol and for some people
some more than others
sugar alcohols in excess can cause a lot
of bloating gas discomfort etc if you
can get away with that without
discomfort along with the 7 grams of
fiber I mean you do you but I feel like
I would be kind of drowning in my own
stash me mmm I think I'm gonna pass on
the gas okay so let's take a look at the
macros
so Megha is consuming about 2600
calories 5% of that is coming from carbs
64% from fat and about 31% from protein
ok so first let's talk about what I'm
liking here number one is that there was
quite a lot of veggies going on
with the exception I think of the
morning meal which yes could use some
veggie love
I liked that both the lunch and the
dinner had lots of colorful veggies
number two there was some good variety
so despite the fact that they of course
were restricting carbs I like that I saw
a nice variety in both the proteins and
the vegetables that were represented
throughout the day and number three
she's consuming enough calories to meet
her caloric needs now I know a lot of
you guys are probably thinking that
seems like a lot of calories especially
in comparison to some of the youtubers
that I've reviewed here previously
however it's important to keep in mind
that women burn about 20 calories per
ounce of breast milk produced put that
in perspective when I was exclusively
breastfeeding my son I was pumping about
47 ounces of milk a day which created a
caloric deficit of about 940 calories so
yeah don't get between a breastfeeding
mama and her food for mega she is an
active young woman so she probably needs
somewhere between 2000 and 2400 calories
baseline add on another 500 to a
thousand calories for breastfeeding and
not her caloric intake makes total sense
she's a woman who is fueling her body
with enough calories to both support
herself and her breastfeeding infant and
sadly in this day and age that deserves
an applause now let's talk about what I
don't love number one there's a lot of
costly expensive keto specific products
now I watched a lot of their videos so
this one wasn't actually too bad when it
comes to the convenience food items and
let's be real I mean they just gave
birth I cannot even believe that they're
cooking anything from scratch because
that was not me but I would say that the
way they're doing the keto diet is very
costly
I mean meat alone beef alone is very
expensive
not to mention all of the supplements
the MCT oil and the collagen and there
was like a grab thingies and the bars
when I watch their videos I just can't
but here you notice a change to change
your tree and I just know that these
things cost a lot of money however I
want you to know that it does not
necessarily have to be that way also the
rain just got like super loud it's like
a tropical rain storm out there so just
bear with us folks
number two was that they were definitely
looking a little low on the fiber so
constipation I already talked about very
common in the keto diet as well as in
pregnancy in postpartum and so with
those vegetables and the good to go bar
we're looking at just around like 17
grams of fiber for the whole day and
most women need between 25 and 30 grams
of fiber promote good gut health and
regularity and lemme tell ya those first
fuel Bal movements post-birth are
traumatizing so if you are feeling a
little bit like your bathroom visit is
childbirths 2.0 do yourself a favor up
the fiber eat some more of those low
carb vegetables choose the carbs very
wisely so they of course you're focusing
on higher fiber sources or of course
take a supplement now i also just
recently saw that they uploaded a video
about why salad is bad i'm gonna need a
whole video to unpack that one for you
but I will just say salad is not bad if
you love salad if you love vegetables
keep eating salad and vegetables and
number three I've got some concerns over
baby's future health and nutrition
generally I'm not really that concerned
about Megas diet I actually think she
represents the keto diet in a pretty
well-balanced way however I really
really hope that they're not gonna be
putting their baby on a keto diet once
they start solids so a breastfeeding
infant is getting about 40 percent of
their calories from carbs in breast milk
so their baby is getting a good source
of carbohydrates right now however when
baby starts solids around six months of
age that baby's gonna need about 95
grams of carbs per day to meet their
caloric needs I actually don't know what
Megas long-term plan is when it comes to
feeding her family if this is something
that she's discussed in detail please
let me know however what I really just
want to do is flag for the rest of you
guys who are watching at home
but the keto diet unless it's medically
supervised for a very specific reason
like epilepsy is really not an
appropriate diet for a child hard stop
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
I am going to be following it up with
another video in a couple weeks where
I'm going to be debunking all of the
claims that Becca and Matt made when it
comes to the idea that salad is bad so
stay tuned for that if you loved this
video be sure to subscribe to the
channel give me the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with another youtuber that
you want me to review and I will see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]